Google app engine has a number of
different options for the types of the properties of an entity,
or if we were to use our old verbiage,
the columns of our table.
Some of the popular ones are
integer, which is for storing integers,
float for storing floating point numbers,
string for storing strings,
and we've got a date for storing dates,
we've got time for storing times,
and then we've got date times
for storing both dates and times.
These are pretty handy.
They even have properties that are things like
email, a link, a postal address.
App engine has all sorts of handy types you can use.
So what I would like to do really quick
is have a little quiz.
We are going to have a couple of properties on our art class.
Properties remember are basically what we have been calling columns.
We're going to have one for the title,
we're going to have 1 for the art,
and I'm going to have another one, I'm going to call it created,
and this is going to be when
the art was submitted to our site.
What I would like you to do is decide
which of these types we should use for
each of these properties,
and oh, by the way, this has turned into a quiz.